[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day we're
gonna be talking about unlimited pasta
but first the Internet's talking about
Drake and for good reason watch this
video so this is from a webbing your old
Sophia Sanchez
she's at the lurie Children's Hospital
in Chicago and she's doing the Kiki
challenge and then of course little
brother we can all relate to that little
brother little sibling so that led to
next video you asked me to come up here
I almost cried and that is a larger
normally okay well do you think she said
no sweetie showed up and like the look
in her face I was like I don't want to
get emotional this is embarrassing where
was the little brother in the second I
was just thinking I want to cut him just
the parents were like you know what can
you come when the kid at school because
little brother I identify with the
little brother oh you can really yes I
understand this is so it's like give him
equal time or else he's gonna wind up on
Comedy Central and again meeting that
attention a little Comedy Central I know
I'm a little brother though
little bro I am the oldest of two so
Nate are you a middle I'm a doll how did
you get here
you middles never make it the middle is
always in the middle so like they die
just Harry Potter and the cursed child
that explains it well Sophia we're
thinking of you and sending you good
thoughts prayers warm wishes we hope
you're doing well and Drake did
something else good watch this
Oh Drake didn't do this so much the
elementary school they're using the Kiki
challenge to get kids to read what do
you think it's cute but I bet the kids
are like kids are so into it that is not
a correct was briefly a middle school
teacher and I did something similar with
to the lyrics to a Lil Wayne song fire
and then I got in trouble because
evidently that song fireman is about
smoking crystal meth which I did not
know so I got trouble I had to talk to
the vice principal oh I was a high
school teacher and I was like when I was
a kid I people butchered my name and so
I'm just like I started the class being
like if anyone has a nickname they want
to use feel free I'm like I'm gonna use
your nickname and all the kids were like
okay cool
I'm gonna go bye little mama
I think that's fine and I wrote that in
and then the next girls like yeah I'm
also gonna go by low and for a week I
had to be like okay little mama what did
you think it's really good it was nice
too I stuck to it and then I came up
with a lie being like you know it's just
hard for roll and like for grading if
there's too many these are the good kids
all the boys like I'm DS who are you I'm
these Drake is out there doing good
thanks to Drake something that may or
may not be good in the world is Olive
Garden is unlimited pasta passin out for
the fifth year in a row jyllian throw
that up so you can for a hundred bucks
you get eight weeks of unlimited pasta
for 300 you can get a whole year
normally their unlimited pasta bowl is
1099 so quite a deal for all those carbs
Times Square whenever I feel homesick so
that's crazy and it's been running for
five years have you ever heard about
this they don't they don't it's not like
movie pass they're not giving unlimited
out there are only twenty eight thousand
won in two thousand last year twenty
three thousand this year and they sold
out in like hours last year right or
like sold it sold out in one second
faster than beyoncé and jay-z's on the
Run tour there's a waiting room like
Coachella you know that is refreshing
know you live near like an Olive Garden
this is an insane dear
pasta your your cheap on the regular
three hundred dollars you could have
unlimited pasta for a year three hundred
over a year's worth of food my god
Hannah that hurts how much your lunch
was every every day like six bucks is a
good deal I don't know how like the
national food bank is not buying all of
these up good hack to solve hunger 52
weeks of unlimited food National Food
Bank and get on this get out to all the
people who are homeless yeah 52 weeks no
drinks the next music video should be
this I don't know seeing the Drake visit
that hospital I'm like how are not all
celebrities doing this all the time
John Cena always goes to those yes he's
like he's the current like celebrity
who's done the most
yeah he's the champion do you guys have
past that you want like unlimited pasta
dental visits I think health care health
care pass may be sponsored by the
government it's almost like it could be
like a single parent
yeah you know a country that could
afford it but only you can only go to
three doctors a day and they're all Mark
Wahlberg my goal just look like Mark
Wahlberg what's Mark Wahlberg's uh
brother's name Donnie hey my
gynecologist is Donnie well I think the
worst part was this weird
this is okay Oh should I do the worm
yeah do the worm right now you can do it
I can do it dance captain why don't we
do it and then we'll just put it in this
part of the show okay here's a clip of
Hannah doing the work guys I actually
I'm getting nervous now I don't think I
can with the way the time and editing
works I wonder if you did a good job
because now we're back yeah I'm sure she
was a worm we'll see it was a worm it
was definitely a word was it be worth
hey leave a comment if you think that
was know whatever epiphany a moment when
you suddenly become conscious of
something that is very important to pot
may have predicted as much stuff
correctly and maastradamus that was an
epiphany in history
[Music]
sure et is a movie about the limitless
love in a boy's heart but it sure feels
like it's about how you should always
lie to your parents
hey what do you wanna do for the outro
this is good I came in just like this
wait now you have to even me out please
like comment subscribe I'll see you next
time you never know sometimes you just
gotta talk a little closer to I did
request that
[Music]
you